women love to compete with each other
they love to be in a room full of women
who they think are less attractive than
them it just is right so then she's like
oh I'm hotter than you hahaha you know
she likes that that little power Dynamic
that happens they say by the way I can't
they say in here oh I love compliments
from women way more when I'm at the gym
first of all no you don't you like
compliments for men more but secondly
the reason you like confidence and
women's is you feel like then you're
hotter than them and you like that you
like that
I can't with this oh we're all in
camaraderie just be honest
you're looking for attention you get it
cool you look good you're working hard
you're earning it you're earning that
booty cool put on the booty shorts and
get the attention and be like yeah I got
attention just own it